Traductor: Florencia Bracamonte
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
A mediados del siglo XVI,
un joven y talentoso anatomista
llamado Andrés Vesalio
hizo un impactante descubrimiento:
los textos de anatomía más famosos
del mundo estaban equivocados.
No omitían únicamente importantes
detalles sobre el cuerpo humano,
sino que además describían
órganos de simios y otros mamíferos.
Si bien Vesalio sabía
que él estaba en lo cierto,
denunciar estos errores significaría
desafiar a Galeno de Pérgamo,
el más afamado médico
en la historia de la medicina.
¿Quién fue este encumbrado médico?
¿Y por qué los médicos 1300 años
más tarde aún lo veneraban y le temían?
Nacido en el 129 d. C., de adolescente
Galeno abandonó su hogar
para explorar el Mediterráneo
en busca de conocimientos médicos.
Regresó convertido
en un talentoso cirujano,
con un gran interés en la anatomía
y una tendencia a la ostentación.
Participaba con gran entusiasmo
en competencias de anatomía,
ansioso de ilustrar a sus colegas médicos.
En una demostración,
hizo que un cerdo perdiera
la voz al atar uno de sus nervios.
En otra, le sacó las entrañas a un mono
y desafió a sus colegas a repararlo.
Cuando ellos no pudieron, él lo hizo.
Gracias a estas grotescas hazañas,
consiguió el puesto de cirujano
de los gladiadores de la ciudad.
Más tarde, dejó la arena para
convertirse en el médico personal
de cuatro Emperadores romanos.
Mientras sus pares debatían
sobre síntomas y sus orígenes,
Galeno se centró en estudiar la anatomía.
Estaba convencido de que cada órgano
cumplía una función específica.
Como el gobierno romano
prohibía, mayormente,
experimentar con cadáveres humanos,
Galeno realizó numerosas
disecciones de animales.
Incluso con esta limitación,
sus incansables investigaciones dieron
lugar a algunas conclusiones muy precisas.
Una de las más importantes
contribuciones de Galeno
fue su comprensión de que el cerebro,
no el corazón, controlaba el cuerpo.
Confirmó esta teoría al abrir
el cráneo de una vaca viva.
Al aplicar presión en
diferentes partes del cerebro,
podía relacionar las distintas regiones
a funciones específicas.
Otros experimentos
le permitieron distinguir
entre nervios sensoriales y motores,
determinar que la orina
se producía en los riñones,
y deducir que la respiración
era controlada por músculos y nervios.
Pero estos sorprendentes experimentos
también condujeron a errores importantes.
Galeno nunca se dio cuenta
de que la sangre circula
de forma constante a través del cuerpo.
Creía más bien que el hígado
producía de forma constante
una cantidad infinita de sangre,
la cual se agotaba en
su viaje de ida hacia los órganos.
Galeno se lleva también el crédito
por reforzar la teoría popular
de los cuatro humores.
Introducida por Hipócrates
unos siglos atrás,
esta equivocada hipótesis establecía
que la mayoría de los problemas de salud
se debían a un desequilibrio
en los cuatro fluidos corporales:
los humores.
Para corregir este balance, los médicos
implementaban peligrosos tratamientos,
como el sangrado y la purga.
Dada esta inadecuada compresión
del sistema circulatorio,
Galeno fue un ferviente defensor
de estos tratamientos,
a pesar de que tenían resultados
en ocasiones letales.
Desafortunadamente,
el ego de Galeno lo llevó a pensar
que todos sus descubrimientos
eran de suma relevancia.
Escribió tratados sobre anatomía,
nutrición, cuidados de los enfermos,
catalogando meticulosamente sus obras
para asegurar su conservación.
Durante los siguientes 13 siglos,
la gran colección de Galeno
imperaba sobre todas
las demás escuelas de pensamiento.
Sus textos se volvieron el material básico
para instruir a los nuevos médicos,
quienes a su vez escribían nuevos ensayos
que enaltecían las ideas de Galeno.
Incluso los médicos
que disecaban cadáveres humanos
repetían, incomprensiblemente,
los errores de Galeno,
a pesar de ver evidencia clara en contra.
Mientras tanto, los pocos médicos osados
que ofrecían opiniones alternas
eran ignorados o ridiculizados.
El legado de Galeno se mantuvo
inalterado por 1300 años,
hasta que el anatomista del Renacimiento,
Vesalio, se expresó en contra.
Como Vesalio era un científico
y orador destacado,
su autoridad influyó en
muchos médicos jóvenes de la época.
Pero incluso entonces,
pasarían otros 100 años
antes de que se produjera una descripción
correcta de la circulación sanguínea,
y 200 años más para que la teoría
de los humores se descartara por completo.
Por suerte,
hoy contamos con los beneficios
de los experimentos de Galeno
sin tener que otorgar igual reconocimiento
a sus ideas menos precisas.
Pero quizá lo valioso sea recordar
que la ciencia es un proceso
en constante cambio
y que se debe poner siempre
la evidencia por sobre el ego.